that's GABA where it's 82 degrees but
it's five hours from here
triple-a predicts a near record number
of Americans will go out of town for
Memorial Day weekend and more of us are
taking shorter more frequent trips Conde
Nast Traveler calls these micro
vacations they tend to involve places
you can get to quickly more often and by
spending less money mark Elwood is
contributing editor for Conde Nast
Traveler mark good morning morning how
is a micro vacation different from a
long weekend trip I think that's a good
question I think often this is a little
bit like tap us for travel there's a
small plate trend so basically a long
weekend I think you'd go somewhere
really nearby or somewhere you're very
familiar with write these micro
vacations are like oh I can just I can
get three hours four hours maybe on a
direct flight yeah that didn't use to
exist there's a lot more connections so
it's widening your options I will
sometimes make a decision based on a
direct flight but are they satisfying
these micro vacations and what
constitutes how many days ISM I would
say it's about three I would say it's
about three or four three or four days
yeah that counts as a micro vacation
substantial there are seven I think it
was about 75% of Americans said they
would tack on an extra day to a weekend
trip now so they're thinking a little
bit bigger and I think that's I think we
all deserve it makes a big difference
you do a few of those instead of one big
trip yeah yeah so when you're booking if
you booked for a long vacation you often
get a better rate per night our hotels
playing nice when a gut microbe Oh Kings
here's the thing I would always suggest
if you're staying more than two nights
you can always call a hotel and
negotiate you can always say hey I'm
gonna stay on Monday night when you may
not be quite so busy can you work with
me on the rate if you're polite if you
ask nicely you'd be surprised how
flexible they won't they won't they
won't you spend their money there so
what are some of the top destinations
for like these three-day trips what's a
way look every year we just we called
the Hot List which is where we look at
the buzziest
the busiest hotels in the world and what
we noticed was that a lot of them now
were opening near major destinations as
well as in them so we've got an amazing
hotel in the Berkshires called the Inn
at Kenmore Hall
not in Boston but reachable from Boston
we've got the hotel Joaquin which is
this model sort of funky upscaled Motor
Inn which is in Laguna Beach not in LA
so you get that little and then if you
if you if you want to go if you're in
Europe or you want to go to London
there's heck field place which is
basically Downton Abbey it's where Harry
and Megan had their baby moon you can
stay there just outside London all right
mark thank you for joining us with your
purple shoes he goes I wanted to be a
little cheeky today Tony's actually
wearing shoes as opposed to I have
normally a much bigger funky socks
I've already heard from neighbors saying
yeah take some advice on this so you can
hear more of CBS this morning on our
podcast that is available of course
wherever you like to download your
podcasts and if you stick around next
we'll look at all that mattered this
week you're watching CBS this morning